thank you Academy thank you uh Sony we
share this with our fellow producers uh
cast a crew there's 800 filmmakers who
push boundaries and took risks
to make people
feel powerful and seen
so when we hear that somebody
somebody's kid was watching the movie
and turned to them and said he looks
like me or they speak Spanish like us we
feel like we already won to our audience
thank you so much we love you and we
just want we want you all to know we see
you you're powerful
this world needs you okay this world
needs you so please we're all counting
on you thank you on behalf of uh
everyone that made this movie we want to
thank our families uh who stay with us
for four years on this this is for you
we love you all
[Music]